sa position ces mouvements tous ces
gestes sont corrigés par son idole l'une
des skieuses nautiques les plus titrés
un rêve pour philippines
elle suit la quintuple championne du
monde depuis son plus jeune âge c'était
une fille gentille de la grande grande
skieuse record aux mains du monde on
s'était pas n'importe qui et voilà et
donc là c'est plaisant d'être épaulé par
l exactement sas beaucoup c'est ça donne
un peu plus de confiance c'est sûr
qu'elle donne beaucoup de bons conseils
voilà toujours avec le sourire est bon
ça motive
je sais pas partir c'était bien tu vas
bien clémentine lucine neuf depuis des
années pour une meilleure connaissance
de sa discipline assurer ces stages de
perfectionnement aujourd'hui à tour lui
permet de poursuivre cette action par
exemple dans des forums dit emballé ski
nautique c'est facile on se fait traîner
derrière un bateau il imagine cette idée
voilà du club med s'est rétracté
derrière un bateau on fait rien c'est
pas du tout ça notre sport et c'est pour
ça que c'est important pour nous à tête
de promouvoir cet aspect là aussi
le club nautique bénéficie depuis peu
d'une meilleure infrastructure et espère
lui aussi une démocratisation de la
discipline pour lui l'objectif est
double de démocratiser la pratique mais
aussi de d'emmener les gens vers une
pratique plus sportive du ski nautique
qui reste pour la grande majorité du
monde plutôt un sport de plage ou un
loisir pour s'essayer à ce sport
nul besoin d'être grand sportif il
suffit de savoir nager